overblown implications effect we think
people judge us by a single success or
failure but they don't if you mess up
one meal no one thinks you're a bad chef
and if you have one great idea no one
thinks you're a genius people just
aren't thinking about you that much
yeah I mean I've when I was young when I
was a teenager I used to suffer from
anxiety
um you know I used to when I would enter
a room I would immediately feel like
everybody was looking at me and I would
feel like at my every micro movement of
my body was being sort of analyzed you
know like as if is like literally like I
was on a reality TV show or something
and um it really was like almost
paralyzing experience and it took me a
long time to really realize that hang on
a second I'm just not that important
like most people just do not give a [__]
about me you know and it was such a
liberated feeling because it's it's true
for a start but also you know it just
helps you to realize
um
to basically take away you know if if
you're focusing on what other people
think about you you won't really live
your life how you want to live it you
won't have that sense of Independence
you'll be completely dependent on what
other people think or what you think
other people think about you but in
reality
people just don't care people are more
worried about how they appear to you
than about how you appear to them
um you know
like 10 years ago if I was to go on this
show like you've got 750 000 subscribers
right if I was here thinking about what
750 000 people are thinking about me you
know while I'm saying these this stuff
right now I'll be paralyzed I wouldn't
be able to do anything I'd be here like
stuttering and I'd just be like you know
I wouldn't be able to say anything
because I just my mind would be
completely filled with the thoughts of
750 000 people thinking of me the way I
look at it is people are going to watch
this episode they'll probably take some
good things from it hopefully if all
goes to plan uh but they won't really
remember
me much they won't remember my uh
mistakes that I said you know whatever
if I said something wrong they won't
really remember it
um they won't focus on it they're not
gonna stalk me I'm not attractive enough
to be stalked so I don't really need to
worry about all of these things you know
um
you know I'm just basically going to
speak too soon mate
yeah
well I think it takes something quite
drastic for that to happen but like um
yeah I mean generally speaking I'm you
know I find that it you just end up
another thing is that you actually end
up looking a lot better to other people
if you don't care too much what they
think of you and this is not to say that
you shouldn't I'm not you know into that
whole you know you should give a [__]
and all that [__] I don't think that's
that's really good I think you should
care what people think but you shouldn't
um you shouldn't be constantly focusing
on what they think of you you know you
should you should just make an effort
just to be relaxed and just to be
yourself
um not not because of
you know like you you want people to
um
I mean really I think the main reason I
want people I think that you should try
to be yourself is because if you try to
be someone who's fake
then you have to essentially create
that character and you have to become
that character so it essentially is a
Prelude to audience capture
um you know if you try to be someone
you're not if you're constantly focusing
on how you appear to others you'll stop
being who you really are and you'll
begin to play to that audience and
you'll essentially be acting in the
Limelight of their gays
and you will cease to be who you
actually are which is I think it's
dangerous I spoke about this in a tedx
talk a couple of years ago and I said
that the Persona is incapable of
receiving love it can only receive
praise and it was something I learned
from Aubrey Marcus that if you're only
playing a role then any compliments that
you receive won't existentially connect
with you inside because it doesn't feel
like someone's complimenting you they're
just complimenting this projection of
what you thought they wanted which is I
don't know I mean sure if you do a
shadow puppet that's really good
fantastic well done look at what you
created but it's not the same as someone
saying you as an individual this very
natural unencumbered projection of your
very essence that you've brought forward
into the world combining all of your
predispositions and genetics with life
experiences and traumas that is worthy
of love and acceptance and praise and
all the rest of it like that's so
fulfilling and it was one of the things
that I read you noticed transitioning
from an industry where I I did have to
be more performative oddly had to be
more performative as a guy stood on the
front door of a nightclub than a guy
that's talks on a podcast
um I found that I would do and say
things that were incongruous with who I
really was even though I wasn't
necessarily doing the self-assessment to
realize it it's only in retrospect that
I got to to work out that I was playing
this role but someone would ask me my
opinion and I would think okay what does
gwynda want to hear from me at this
moment what what should I say in order
to engender the most positive response
that I can get from him and it was
[__] crippling like it was it was
absolutely crippling because I'm
permanently playing this meta me game
I'm always having to be one degree of
separation removed I don't actually have
an opinion I don't actually hold any
truths myself what I hold are various
avatars that I all need to exist in my
mind at one time because the the you
that I am the me that I am for you and
the me that I am for my housemate and
the me that I am for my mum and the me
that I am for all of the other people in
my life all need to be very carefully
held and and remembered and what did I
say to him last time what was my opinion
about that did I think it was going to
be Tommy Fury or Jake Paul that was
going to win and like all of that all of
that it's incredible computationally
it's basically impossible
it is yeah I mean there's a quote that's
been attributed to um Mark Twain I don't
know if he actually said it but it's
attributed to him and it's um something
like uh if you tell the truth then you
don't need to remember anything and I
think that that really saves you a lot
of energy you know if you are just who
you really are and you just are relaxed
and just say what you really think and
you don't try to put on a front
it just saves so much energy in in
interactions you know I used to be
exhausted in interaction social
interactions because I was constantly
acting I was constantly trying to
impress or I was constantly trying to be
the person that I thought people
expected me to be and it like you said
you know it's just this constant sort of
computational
sort of power like just to be you know
your brains being Fried by all this you
know circuitry firing off and um it's
just not good because you end up not
being who you really are and you end up
yourself you end up sort of exhausting
yourself uh to be someone who you you
who you're not and at the end of it all
people probably don't even [__]
remember so yeah after all of them
didn't even [__] care yes
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
foreign